L'amour en fuite c'est le film de
François truffau tourné en
1978 que nous vous proposons à 20h30 une
suite de plus à l'itinéraire sentimental
d'Antoine douanel interprété par
Jean-Pierre Léo le héroch chéri de
François truffo il est entouré de Claude
Jade marie-fance Pisier et Dorothée à
22h05 ce sera la dernière édition de
Soir 3 puis à
22h30 nous vous proposons dans la conte
d'Italie hiver de malade un téléfilm
d'Alberto Moravia réalisé par Carlo
lidzi qui retrace la vie d'un jeune
homme condamné à une cure de
soleil nous terminerons notre soirée en
musique avec prélude à la nuit ce soir
fantasy hhtuk auus 88 de Schuman très
bonne soirée à tous sur
FR3